This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. My name is Melissa Lee and originally I'm from Hastings on Hudson, New York. A small town I suppose you have to make your own fun. Everybody makes their own fun if you don't make it yourself it ain't fun it's entertainment. I guess the big activity would be walking downtown after school and you could hang out by the wall and watch people that you knew go by. So not a lot going on in Hastings on Hudson, New York. It's about two square miles but it's right outside New York City so it's sort of like you know
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。我叫梅丽莎·李，老家是纽约州哈德逊河畔黑斯廷斯。那是个小镇，我想你得自己找乐子。每个人都在找自己的乐子，如果你不自己找，那就不是乐子，而是娱乐。我想主要的活动就是放学后步行去市中心，你可以在墙边闲逛，看着认识的人走过。所以纽约州哈德逊河畔黑斯廷斯并没有太多事情发生。它大约有两平方英里，但它就在纽约市旁边，所以有点像
there's a lot out there to do but there's not actually a lot to do right where I was. Besides people watching, let's say in her friends would also collect geodes. We did collect geodes yes. You know about geodes right? Break your own geodes. The rocks are brown and won't be on the outside, but when you smash them apart. Inside would be some crystal on structures. And you have no idea from the outside what you're getting.
外面有很多事情可做，但实际上我所在的地方并没有多少可做的事。除了看人，比方说她和朋友们还会收集晶洞。我们确实收集过晶洞，是的。你知道晶洞吧？自己砸开晶洞。石头是褐色的，外面看起来普普通通，但当你把它们砸碎时。里面会是一些晶体结构。而且你从外表根本不知道里面会是什么。
So you kind of take a chance on it that inside you've got something great. Usually Melissa and her friend Liz would buy a few geodes at the store downtown and take them home and smash them apart with a hammer. but one day when Melissa was 13. We were too impatient and we just had to know what was inside. There was a parking lot nearby with an apartment building and we decided to throw it against the side of the wall as hard as we could and hope that it would crack open that way.
所以你有点像是在碰运气，看里面有没有什么好东西。通常梅丽莎和她的朋友莉兹会在市中心的商店买几个晶洞，带回家然后用锤子把它们砸碎。但当梅丽莎13岁的那天。我们太不耐烦了，非得知道里面是什么不可。附近有一栋带公寓楼的停车场，我们决定把它朝墙上砸，有多用力就砸多用力，希望它能那样裂开。
And I think that was the first time that we had tried to open them that way without a hammer just by throwing it. So I threw mine a few times and finally it did crack open against the wall and Liz kept throwing her is and it wouldn't crack open. There's only one little window in this whole back of this apartment building. My friend Liz kept throwing hers and and Liz kept throwing her is and it wouldn't crack open Um So I threw mine and we saw it going towards the window and then I mean it felt like it was slow motion
我想那是我们第一次不用锤子，只靠扔的方式来尝试打开它们。所以我把我的扔了几次，最后它确实在墙上撞裂了，而莉兹一直在扔她的，但就是砸不裂。这栋公寓楼背面整面墙只有一个小窗户。我的朋友莉兹一直在扔她的，莉兹一直在扔她的，但就是砸不裂嗯……所以我扔了我的，我们看到它朝窗户飞去，然后，我的意思是感觉就像慢动作一样
Her aim just went wild and kind of like nooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo the geod went through the window, went right through the window, breaking the glass and shattering it everywhere. We were at this huge crashing sound. Glass had broken and was now lying all over the parking lot floor and the geod was inside. My first reaction was just pure full-on fear. I hated doing things wrong, I hated getting in trouble and I just got that terrible sinking feeling in my stomach and I just wanted to get out of there. We were such good kids. I mean, this is what we did for fun. We broke open geodes.
她的瞄准完全偏了，就像诺~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~~那个晶洞穿过了窗户，径直穿过窗户，把玻璃撞得粉碎，散落得到处都是。我们听到了一声巨大的破碎声。玻璃碎了，现在散落了满停车场都是，而晶洞则在里面。我的第一反应是纯粹的、全方位的恐惧。我讨厌做错事，我讨厌惹麻烦，我的胃里顿时涌起那种可怕的下坠感，我只想离开那里。我们是那么好的孩子。我的意思是，这就是我们消磨时光的方式。我们砸开晶洞。
We never did anything wrong. And now we had committed this heinous act. And it was sort of like the quintessential wrong thing that kids can do. I mean, you always, I always saw, you know, TV shows or red comic books where kids would break a window. I didn't like that. And then they had their face with a dilemma. They go back and tell the guy that they did it or not. Hey, it looks good on you.
我们从来没做过坏事。而现在我们却犯下了这桩滔天大罪。这有点像是孩子们能做的那种典型错事。我的意思是，你总是，我总是看到，你知道，电视剧或看漫画书里孩子们会打破窗户。我不喜欢那样。然后他们就面临着两难境地。他们是回去告诉那个人是他们干的还是不告诉？嘿，这很适合你。
We froze for about 10 seconds. And then my friend, Liz, ran forward. She reached into the broken glass and grabbed the geode and we both ran. After initially running, some sort of moral compass started up and we realized that we had to go back and we had to find this person and tell them what we did. Listen Liz went back to the apartment building. And we tried to figure out where the window led to, but when we ran around to the front it was very confusing which door might lead to that window. And so we knocked on a few doors, everyone who's door we knocked on said that it wasn't their window. You know, we probably did that for 10 minutes and then I think we were like, well,
我们呆立了大约10秒钟。然后我的朋友莉兹向前跑去。她把手伸进碎玻璃里抓起晶洞，然后我们俩都跑了。最初的一阵狂奔之后，某种道德罗盘开始运作，我们意识到我们必须回去，我们必须找到这个人并告诉他们我们做了什么。听着，莉兹回到了公寓楼。我们试图弄清楚那个窗户通向哪里，但当我们跑到正面时，很难分清哪扇门能通往那个窗户。于是我们敲了几扇门，我们敲门的所有人都说那不是他们的窗户。你知道，我们大概敲了10分钟，然后我想我们就在想，好吧，
I think we did all that we can do. And we were probably really glad that we tried, but we weren't able to find out who's window it was in the end. Still feeling guilty, Melissa avoided downtown and the window for a couple of months, which wasn't easy in a small town. I thought that we would just go about our business
我想我们已经尽力了。而且我们可能真的很庆幸我们尝试过了，但最终我们没能找出那是谁的窗户。由于内心依然充满负罪感，梅丽莎有好几个月都避开市中心和那扇窗户，在一个小镇上这可不容易。我以为我们会照常过日子
and somebody would fix the window and I would never have to think about it again. But when Melissa finally did go back to the window, it was still broken. Like a cartoon, just like a, you know, jagged edge hole that was sitting there. Even the glass shards that had fallen into the parking lot were still lying there. It was pretty much like in pristine condition from the day that we had broken it until months and months later. It stayed almost exactly the same. It was clear that the apartment was occupied. Actually, we could see it TV on inside
然后有人会修好窗户，而我再也不用去想它了。但当梅丽莎终于回到那扇窗户前时，它依然是破的。就像动画片里那样，就像一个锯齿边缘的洞就摆在那里。甚至掉进停车场的玻璃碎片也依然躺在那里。从我们打破它的那一天起，到几个月甚至几年后，它几乎一直保持着崭新的原状。它几乎原封不动。很明显，这间公寓是有住人的。实际上，有时我们能看到里面开着电视
sometimes. So we knew somebody did live there. And sometimes the window would be raised up or lowered down. So someone was moving this window around, but the hole was always still in it. We just could not even imagine who this person was that wasn't doing anything to fix this window. They weren't even putting tape over it. And we'd even go buy in the winter and see that the hole is still there. The window stayed broken. As Melissa finished middle school, then finished high school. It just hadn't gone away like I wanted it to. The window went to college. And I was shocked to find that it was still broken.
有时。所以我们知道确实有人住在那里。有时窗户会被推上去或拉下来。所以有人在动这扇窗户，但洞却一直都在。我们简直无法想象这个人到底是谁，居然对这扇窗户不修补。他们甚至连胶带都没贴。我们甚至在冬天路过时也看到洞还在。窗户依然破着。随着梅丽莎读完初中，然后读完高中。它就是没有像我希望的那样消失。窗户都上大学了。而我震惊地发现它居然还是破的。
Even after I'd left town. And this became the pattern for Melissa. She'd go away, do some growing up. But when she came home, she'd see that window and feel exactly like the 13-year-old kid she was when she broke the window. When I think about 13, that's like my most awkward, horrible age. The sight of this window would just bring me right back to feeling like a middle school
甚至在我离开小镇之后。这就成了梅丽莎的模式。她会离开，经历成长。但当她回到家时，她会看到那扇窗户，感觉自己完全就是当年打破窗户那个13岁的孩子。每当我想起13岁，那简直是我最尴尬、最可怕的年纪。看到这扇窗户就会把我瞬间拉回到那种初中生的感觉
or again. Melissa is 36 now. Thinking of all the milestones you passed between 13 and 36. I went away to college for four years and by the end of that I felt pretty grown up. Came home, saw the window, felt like a 13-year-old. And then after that I traveled the world for nine months. Came home, saw the window, felt like a 13-year-old. I went to graduate school, came home.
或者是这样。梅丽莎现在36岁了。想想你在13岁到36岁之间经历的所有人生节点。我离家上大学四年，到最后我觉得自己已经挺成熟了。回到家，看到窗户，觉得自己像个13岁的孩子。在那之后，我环游世界九个月。回到家，看到窗户，觉得自己像个13岁的孩子。我读了研究生，回到了家。
I moved to Washington, D.C. Saw the window. I got married. You get the idea. As much as I was changing, this part of my past was completely frozen. As soon as I saw the windows, just brought right back to those middle school days when we had broken it. So in 2011, when I'm about 35 years old, 22 years after
我搬到了华盛顿特区。看到了窗户。我结婚了。你懂我的意思。尽管我在不断改变，但我过去的这部分却完全冰冻了。一看到这扇窗户，我就立刻回到了我们打破它的初中时代。所以在2011年，当我大约35岁的时候，也就是
she and her friend broke the window. I decided to find out once and for all who's window it is and apologize. And I guess, you know, offered a pay for it as well. Now I'm recording this time for real. I don't want to be in the oil. So I go downtown with my sister accompanying me for courage. The whole is still there in the window. And my heart is beating so fast. Should I just say, I'm sorry, I didn't mean to upset you, I just, I believe that, that like I know who broke that window
她和她的朋友打破窗户22年之后。我决定彻底查清楚这扇窗户到底是谁的并去道个歉。我想，你知道，也提出为此赔偿。现在我正在录音，这次是真的。我不想在油里。所以我去了市中心，我的姐姐陪着我以壮胆。窗户上的洞还在。我的心脏跳得好快。我是不是该直接说，对不起，我不是故意打扰你的，我只是，我相信，我，就像我知道是谁打破了那扇窗户一样
Okay, and I very very nervously blurt out. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm not trying to bother you I'm just trying to actually make amends for I think that years ago I'm not sure but I think my friend and I broke that window and so I kind of just wanted to make amends for it You're broken. I think so. You're telling me now? Well, I actually tried to find you at the time, and I couldn't find you. And then 20 years later, I came back to my hometown. I left, you know, I haven't been back since then.
好的，我非常非常紧张地脱口而出。对不起。对不起。我不是想打扰你，我只是想弥补一下，我觉得几年前，我不确定，但我认为我和我的朋友打破了那扇窗户，所以我只是想为此做出弥补你的窗户破了。我想是的。你现在才告诉我？其实我当时想找你，但我找不到你。然后20年过去了，我回到了我的家乡。我离开了，你知道，从那以后我再也没回来过。
And basically, that's what happened. So I just wanted to kind of find out, you know, who's it was. And I know, good. She Keep me looking for me 20 years. You just said you found me. You believe it? We're 20 years. Well, I left town for a while.
基本上，事情就是这样。所以我只是想查清楚，你知道，这是谁的。我知道，好。她让我找了20年。你刚才说你找到了我。你相信吗？我们20年了。嗯，我离开小镇一段时间了。
But he didn't want to talk to me. He thought it was amusing that I was now fessing up. And when I offered to pay for it, he said, Is this window? No, forward. No? I'm surprised. I know. Well, why did you just decide to leave it like that? Got a nice breeze in the back there. The landlord had never fixed it. And when I offered to pay for it, he said, no, that he'd gotten used to it, he'd just left it. I can't wait till I walk the window and be dead. It's like I love it.
但他不想跟我谈。他觉得我现在来自首这件事挺逗的。当我提出要赔偿时，他说，这是窗户吗？没有，往前。没有？我很惊讶。我知道。那你们为什么决定就让它那样放着？后面有很好的微风。房东从来没修过。当我提出赔偿时，他说不，他已经习惯了，就任由它那样。我等不及走到窗户前死掉了。就像我爱它一样
I wouldn't get a fix for nothing. Anyway, I'm sorry, but I'm glad that you've come to like the broken window. My name is Melissa by the way. Okay. Thank you. It was nice to meet you after all these years. I've wondered about it. That's kind of an understatement. What ever it was that was keeping me stuck in middle school
我绝不会把它修好的。不管怎样，对不起，但我很高兴你能喜欢这扇破窗户。顺便说一句，我叫梅丽莎。好的。谢谢你。这么多年后很高兴见到你。我一直很好奇。这真可以说是轻描淡写了。无论是什么把我困在初中时代
there was sort of keeping him stuck with this broken window. And he just was content to live with it. The Broken Windows Theory proposed in 1982 says that a seemingly small act of vandalism, if it goes unfixed, can precipitate further vandalism and even more serious crime. That really didn't happen here, except for Melissa's life on the land for 20 years. But the Broken Window did way on Melissa, and I'm guessing it affected the man in the apartment more than he's letting on, and a random passerby, less so, and hastings on Hudson
某种程度上也把他困在了这扇破窗户里。而他满足于带着它生活。1982年提出的破窗效应认为，看似微小的破坏行为如果不加修复制止，会引发进一步的破坏甚至更严重的犯罪。这里其实并没有发生那种事，除了梅丽莎背负了20年的人生。但破窗户确实压在梅丽莎心头，我猜它对公寓里的那个男人的影响比他表现出来的要多，而对路过的陌生人则影响较小，而哈德逊河畔黑斯廷斯
New York soldiered on without missing a beat. Architecture is personal. The strangest part of our interaction with the built environment is what can be so evocative and meaningful for you can mean absolutely nothing to someone else. This time when I was in town, I just didn't really even, I think I was even in town for a few days before I even thought about the window. I didn't really even wonder about it very much. And then in the end, I didn't even go down and look.
纽约继续坚定前行，步伐未乱。建筑是个人化的。我们与建成环境互动中最奇怪的部分在于，对你来说如此唤起回忆、意义重大的一切，对别人来说可能完全没有任何意义。这次我在镇上时，我甚至都没有，我想我甚至在镇上呆了好几天才想起那扇窗户。我其实根本没怎么去想它。最后，我甚至都没有走过去看一眼。
99% invisible is Sam Green Greenspan and me Roman Mars. It's a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars. But this week you have to see the original art by a meal homewood of the caravan illustrating this story that you just heard. It just makes me so happy.
“99%隐形”节目的制作人是萨姆·格林斯潘以及我罗曼·马斯。这是旧金山本地公共电台KALW 91.7以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并关注这个节目。我在推特上的账号是Roman Mars。但本周你一定要看看由埃米尔·霍姆伍德创作的原创艺术作品，那辆大篷车描绘了你刚才听到的这个故事。这真的让我太开心了。
Check it out at 99%ivisible.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. Radio Tepi. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 99%ivisible.org 查看。Radio Tapio。来自 PRX。Radio Tepi。来自 PRX。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。